[Music]
two pranksters
why are you looking at me like that i
don't know
i should look him i'm not a prankster
that guy's a prankster yeah two
pranksters are jailed for simulating a
sex act outside the moscow cathedral
they're blowing each other
or mocking blowing each other
i'll just give it straight to you they
don't [ __ ] around and rush that dude
yeah boom oh [ __ ] they're fully clothed
you can go to jail for this [ __ ] russia
dude you don't play around beyond belief
in russia yeah russian all played what
is in russia you're just talking to a
guy at a bus stop and you're like yeah
man that's great you know yeah
and the guy's on his knees
no you guys sitting on a bench at the
bus stop in front of the cathedral
with the photo that you post on
instagram but are they influencers these
folks haven't been to california i had a
gym member coming to the gym the other
day and said you want to see what i just
saw up the street so what's up bro shows
me a picture
two homeless people just straight spread
eagle catalingus all over the [ __ ]
sidewalk ladies like this on the
sidewalk and dudes stomach down on the
sidewalk just buffeting at 9am
in the morning
i'm totally naked both of them i thought
you're gonna say he's like you wanna see
what i just saw outside and he takes off
your pants and he starts sucking your
knife
you hear about this russian story and
puts a photo of the moscow cathedral
behind him
it's me yeah he's going like this
two instagram jokers have been jailed
for simulating a sex act outside the
cathedral in the russian capital moscow
uh i'm not even gonna say his name
because i'm gonna butcher the [ __ ] out
of business i'll try it i'll try it okay
that's hard to
have since apologized for the antics
which took place outside the famous
saint basil's cathedral in red square
but uh that hasn't saved them from
prison that's the wrong country to do it
yeah yeah you can't be doing that type
of [ __ ]
they sound like they're russian no yeah
yeah
they know if you want to [ __ ] around
[ __ ] around in america dude yeah this is
like the safe place you don't want to do
that in mexico [ __ ] it's not as
[ __ ] in america there's a bunch of
people with sticks up their asses but
also this bit of that picture not a good
[ __ ] that's not funny it's not even hard
it wasn't even worth going to jail for
yeah not even worth taking a picture for
them he got sentenced
maybe you just chopped his dick off old
school you know you used to rob [ __ ]
they cut your fingers off yeah ten years
firing squad how about that 30 years
that's what you guys actually believe
30 years i believe they deserve the
firings i'm thinking about it a russian
mentality think about what you if you
were the judge ten years because they
thought it was a prank and it wasn't
funny
yeah that's backcon this is what i know
about russia okay so i know a russian
weightlifter named klokov and he said
every morning his dad made him jump in
an ice cold lake and now all the
elementary school kids did that yeah
that would be tough that's my thought
process of russia they're just wanky
wakey yeah yeah they're just different
they're good at everything too yeah so
10 years i don't know okay all right
fair fair 30 years firing squad dude you
guys are intense stand by all right i'm
thinking with my russian squad
this one let's say maybe this is your
you're a prankster and this is your
prank in front of our history yeah
religious place yeah come on dude better
is it religious
it's a mosque i think it's a cathedral
it's a cathedral oh they're found guilty
of offending the feelings of religious
people at moscow's uh oh [ __ ] off
it's one of the worst things i've ever
heard and they'll serve 10 months in
prison 10 months they should do more
well she got soft
dude imagine 10 months for just taking a
stupid [ __ ] picture though fully
clothed you're the one who said firing
squad i still stand by it it's either
it's either it's either a fine or a
firing squad that's it if you're talking
about a place where all the kids jump
into a [ __ ] frozen lake in the
morning
what do you think russian prisons like
guys
that's the cool dog bro 10 months is
probably 10 years easy they're gonna die
they're gonna die in there yeah it's
probably like 10 months check out my
clock no batteries yeah it walks away
that's it no one's keeping track of how
long you don't even have bars it's just
[ __ ] icicles it's just an ice [ __ ]
jail dude
with [ __ ] polar bears i know it's
like a black widow movie you know it's
the same type of prison people say that
though i've heard prisons around the
world are like a billion times worse
than america yeah have you seen this el
salvadorian ones bro
there's a whole series called locked up
abroad is it is it only the american
prisons the one that present the whole
like gay sex element what do you mean
like a first like this the the
stereotype or like the idea that like
when you go to prison don't drop the
soap i don't think that's a stereotype
or not
isn't that only in america i think
that's a real thing yeah i think there's
only gay people in america dude all the
gays in jail well didn't you hear putin
he said that there's no or it was it was
ahmadinejad yeah
he he was the president
russia just did it too russia literally
just did it like last week yeah we don't
have gay people what are you talking
about there's no gay people here they
literally said there's no gay people in
russia and iran the iran's presidency
yeah we don't have gay people no they
don't exist i think that's a 2020
interview or something like that but
they why do we have so many gay people
there i don't know they're all the
russians they're free here yeah
reclusive dude because they run away
from iran and russia to come here that's
why it's called iran iran
is that was that a danger
it came in my mouth i swallowed the back
you're the [ __ ] dad here why aren't
you saying this [ __ ] quicker uh swac
well obviously the russian authorities
didn't find it very amusing uh and she
was wearing a police jacket whilst
kneeling down in front of them that's a
little worse like you know for the
russian response
officer i have no idea
right they're known as online pranksters
the guy is known uh usually known as
online prankster his partner crime who's
just 19 years old is an instagram model
uh described as his girlfriend i'm not
gonna lie she she's pretty fine she's um
she's probably got her only fans she's
up there we like it she's gonna she's
gonna be in prison for 10 months that's
funny that's wild bro did she go to
chick prison
probably do they do they do that i don't
know
do they do that in general
that's what it is isn't it it's not the
russian prisoner if it still is it used
to be in the ussr right
damn it could be really sketchy yeah i
bet before she learned of her fate as a
sentence was handed down she shared a
post on her instagram account that
stated i would like to apologize before
those whose feelings are hurt by these
pictures i didn't think and simply
wanted likes and popularity now i
realize the price of such popularity
matter of fact don't we all and i have
to answer it to the fullest extent of
the law with my freedom public
condemnation and disapproval should have
just said i forgot i lived in russia she
should have sucked a real dick yeah
you're sucking a fake dick for clout you
think it's like don't judge that now
it's like actually dedicated to the
judge's dick that's i like that double
jeopardy dude yeah
i can't get you for the same time twice
i want to know what the guy's content
looks like i want to know what kind of
prank price sucks yeah it's probably and
now we're going to get like now we're
going to give them likes and views and
followers because she just made 10k but
what kind of pranks can you make if
you're worried about offending religious
people that's true you have to do the
it's not a real sandwich prank or
whatever the [ __ ] what's that what's
that really like you're like hey look at
this
i'm about to have a ham sandwich
and then there's no ham in it
oh it's just bread how does he do it
it's just bread
you [ __ ] idiot
and then all these religious people are
doubling over with laughter
like how do you [ __ ] make religious
people laugh good luck what would you
say is the craziest prank video that you
ever did that i did yeah
i didn't get to do it bro oh let's hear
it though tell you guys off camera again
it's that bad yeah it's pretty well i
thought russia was like just barely
religious like because they had that
whole [ __ ] communism and
anti-religion [ __ ] that's crazy i didn't
know they were so heavily deep are they
very christian or like catholic yeah i
think they're catholic catholic right
they're no they're orthodox christian
orthodox christians how much time do you
think eastern europeans what's the other
catholic there's there's catholic
there's orthodox christian and there's
protestants no no there's another
catholic and i think it's russian roman
catholic no no no that's the norm
russian catholic i think it is like an
eastern lutheran i think it's eastern
orthodox catholic that's the orthodox
presbyterian i think they're i think
they're basically catholic or russia
it's like just russia well there's a big
russian population that's like very
muslim too you know yeah yeah yeah i
mean that's what's funny about america
is like muslims by far the biggest
religion on the planet yeah by far but
just not here because we although we're
separate it's a christian yeah for sure
maybe it's not so much just religion but
like the symbolism of like the red
square and like that cathedral being
such an iconic thing don't be [ __ ]
with mother russia that's what they're
saying yeah yeah it's like i heard i
heard i don't know
you've been in russia i have been
arrested i heard everyone sad as [ __ ] uh
in the winter it does look sad in the
summer i'm like whoa what's up russian
ladies
but uh i do i do remember hearing a
story uh and somebody correct me if i'm
[ __ ] wrong with this but um when they
made that cathedral back in the day
i heard that the architect
got killed or blinded afterwards so he
can never make another one oh my god
that's some hardcore russian [ __ ] i'm
rushing [ __ ] that's what i'm saying
russians are [ __ ] soft that's the
most russian [ __ ] i've ever heard i can
understand where like you know
that area maybe not so much just the
religious act thank you for making such
beautiful work of art now i will reward
you with death he couldn't just promise
like i promise i won't swear to god i
want that's where to get out i don't
want anybody else to copy this [ __ ] i
swear on this church i won't do this
again i guess that's what builds legends
i don't believe promise yeah let me have
your eyeballs
i don't believe you're [ __ ]
no that's [ __ ] hardcore i mean you
can't be sucking dick in front of that
you know what i mean somebody [ __ ]
fix like an architect lost his eyes and
died to that [ __ ] you gave me a fake
sucking dick
dude whoever did the [ __ ] freedom
tower should lose his eyes that [ __ ]
looks wacky what's that what's the
freedom tower the new world trade center
oh i haven't seen it [ __ ] it's just
one
whatever washington monument what the
[ __ ] is that bro they should have had a
building that's like this face in europe
yeah
it's like a double bird
that was that was a meme right before
they actually built it it wasn't yeah it
was a meme that was like one of the
earliest memes when it was like we're
gonna rebuild yeah they should have
created the twin towers like this and it
had a [ __ ] bridge that said [ __ ]
terrorists oh yeah trump was an
architect
you